vous avez remarqué une misogynie de la
part de vos collègues masculins oui
absolument il existe très fortement sur
certains bancs de l'assemblée nationale
les députés victimes de sexisme ça a
commencé dès leur arrivée à l'assemblée
dans la cour du palais monsieur edouard
herriot président du parti radical
jean-louis marin
et puis des fans des communistes et des
socialistes
et puis des femmes voilà comment étaient
présentés en 1945 les 33 premières
femmes élues députées du sexisme
ordinaire que l'on retrouve aussi chez
cette journaliste en 1963
votre mari il a accepté sans difficulté
que vous exerciez ce mandat oui du
sexisme de la part des journalistes mais
aussi au sein même de l'hémicycle il y a
eu à vaincre eu un certain nombre de
mentalité à vaincre des esprits
retardataires des esprits retardataires
qui seront sans cesse dénoncée il est
vrai que
il m'arrive de recueillir d'entendre des
interjections qui sont assez déplacé et
en 2012 la scène est filmée madame
cécile duflot ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
monsieur le président les coûteux
mesdames et messieurs les députés mais
surtout messieurs visiblement des
sifflets qui font la une des médias mais
non contents de leur petit effet
certains députés persiste et signe voit
qu'elle pique je refais argent fou un an
plus tard alors qu'une députée à la
parole
un collègue imitent les caquètements
d'une poule ans ça suffit mais qui ce
qui s'y fait que de 0,1 j'ai pas une
poule 1 c'est bon cette fois c'en est
trop je pensais même pas que ça existait
un comportement comme celui là j'ai
compris que c'est parce que je suis une
femme pour la première fois toutes les
députés de gauche décide de marquer le
coup pour dire stop en faisant une
arrivée groupée dans l'hémicycle de son
côté le député philippe le ray hauteur
des bruits de poule sera sanctionné avec
un rappel à l'ordre est privée d'un
quart de son indemnité pendant un mois
malgré ces rappels à l'ordre et ces
sanctions le sexisme dans l'hémicycle a
toujours lieu les députés en première
ligne mais aussi les journalistes
politiques qui décident de lancer une
pétition en 2015 on avait tout d
anecdotes notamment sur des propos
sexistes déplacer sexisme aussi du côté
des assistantes parlementaires qui
décide de prendre la parole en 2017 il
ya des noms de parlementaires qui
circulait entre collaboratrice parce
qu'on savait qu'il fallait pas prendre
l'ascenseur avec eux si je sais quoi
parce qu'il y avait un risque qui vous
colle une main aux fesses qu' il ya eu
des histoires du sexisme ordinaire dans
l'enceinte même où le texte ou contre
les violences sexistes et voter
[Musique]